yeah hello and welcome to this video
um yeah so i'm going to start a new game
that game here um i think it was not
worth i'm putting out
a video for because it was just like
i gave this check here on before and
white went knight d2 and after bishop c3
i'm oops
i was wrong i'm winning in exchange and
white just
simply resigned knight c2 is just
limiting the damage to an exchange
so i don't want to upload an 8 move game
so let's go for a new game
and the search is usually rather rather
fast 3 plus 2
you nowadays get a game quite quite
quickly there are so many players on the
platform
so let's hope that it doesn't take ages
and i've got black again so um
yeah let's play that
reversed cup of very not reversed m
improved cup of is what it's usually
called
at e5 knight c6 bishop c5 um
i get that on the board i guess uh
interesting yeah this is actually a
small move on a nuance to play knight c3
first
and not bishop g2 interesting
not many people do that so he knows
about this
little detail okay
now i'm taking as the usual solution
and now knight e7 intending to go to f5
and increase the pressure on the d4 pawn
the main
issue let's say or the main
oh interesting
um it's kind of a deja vu i think
i think i've looked at this
or i've had this on the board i think i
can actually take
because of d5 b5
now i have one moment i have knight d3
now right
i don't have anything better i think
knight e5 is is a move
but this is certainly fine
now he will move the king clearly no
other way to play
and then i have a choice i can play
knight to e5
or i can play knight c5 also
okay um let's see
knight e5
queen g5 doesn't do anything i believe
if i go knight e5 i have to check
um the capture on a6 but then i have
bishop b7 that's easy
b6 bishop d7
now it has no way that this is not good
for black it's just not possible
maybe maybe uh knight c5 is a is a good
alternative instead
but this is certainly okay i
always have knight c5 you have to
secure the knight on d3 but
let's check this for a moment i can also
take on b5 here
certainly possible
this is fine yeah this is fine where is
he going
to b4
we could play a5 against that
a5
a5 and then the check on c form
it's really funny
no it's going all the way back so i have
the check now here right
but yeah come on
let's just
oh bishop f5 wow
um okay
the poor king what has he done to
deserve this
okay so simply knight takes e4
winning winning the house
[Music]
yeah i think i had exactly the same
thing
in a game with with this before
yeah certainly no rematch i mean it's
always a bit
awkward i like to do a rematch in
general but i want to look at the games
as well
and so i'm fairly certain i had the same
thing maybe if somebody
looks wants to look through the videos
um
i'm fairly certain i had the same thing
and maybe actually there is this
explorer um
here where can you that is master
games wait i can you can somehow
set this up how do you do that again
um ah here i think
lead chess
so this one seriously
they had it had that two that was
happened
two times against the same guy
that's that's crazy that is crazy
that is crazy let me let me check
quickly
yeah he played the same one month ago
he played the same stuff guy that's not
good
learn from your mistakes okay that's
that's really cool okay so maybe now he
has realized that this is not a good
idea to play before
anyway so let's have a look at the the
actual game that was just played
so i took it and well clearly queen a4
was the intention
knight ec6 d5 b5 and
this is already i think awful right man
it's just awful
i'm winning a pawn and the whole um
yeah position is also collapsing quite
quite badly it's the problem night
coming here and
well awful so he took
got the check king d2 and yeah
knight c5 certainly a good alternative
i'm not sure if this is
worse in any way i don't think it can be
um if he takes i always have this one
and b6 similarly is answered with bishop
d7
it looks a little bit more complicated
but
it doesn't really have a good move i
mean those pieces are now
the knight are the knights are secured
and the engine wants to play queen h4
which is
basically the same as resigning
i mean here i'm a pawn up
even i mean not that this is the most
important but
on top of everything i'm a pawn up and
the position is of course
completely collapsing went f4
knight c5 queen d1
and then good king e1 has to be played
but what kind of a position is that
yeah and now he resigned so simply this
before move
is just not possible um i think
um
no
i wanted like a castle castle you can
still not play before right i think he
also can simply take him
i don't think it's it's possible to play
it so early on like as a pawn sacrifice
not just not
just not on okay guys thanks for
watching